hello my name is John Bernthal and I
feel extraordinarily lucky oh that's
being Conan O'Brien's friend that is
really nice yeah I like that you know
I've always liked you you came on our
show a couple times we clicked and I was
all excited you were coming on the show
and then I suddenly had an attitude
about it this morning an attitude yeah
and I'll tell you why tell me because a
guy who works here Aaron Blair we call
him blay yeah it's just before you're
going to be here and everyone's excited
that you're coming in everyone here is a
big fan oh man and I'm excited that
you're coming in I'm excited that you're
coming in and then Blaze says yeah he's
such a he's man he's just amazing
amazing he said you know it's weird and
he wasn't doing a joke he said Conan in
a lot of ways he's your opposite and I
was like what anyway you know because
he's so cool and he's like a real man's
man and I was like no no seriously
seriously and everyone in the room was
like yeah yeah he's the uh he's like
he's like the alternate and the minute
and the nicest way about you
um and then I suddenly I was like [ __ ] I
think they're right I I so I would
strongly disagree listen so I was just
gonna say I was very tempted when you
came in to find to fight you but to wait
until some woman when you were
vulnerable you know I want to do it I
want to come at you when you don't
expect it I wanted uh Gurley to distract
you and I wanted to I wanted to have
like a large stick or something so I was
going to win in a completely and still
you would have taken the broken stick
out of my hand I don't know about that
you know what's crazy is I have these
memories of of doing your show and you
were so you know it's such a horrifying
thing to do those shows you know when
you're you're starting out and you were
so good to me and one time I forgot my
shoes I don't know if you have it you
probably have no no memory of that but
you gave me your own personal shoot they
were way too big and I wore them on the
show and you're so good to me and and
then and then you left with my [ __ ]
shoes and ever since then and you wear
them even as The Punisher right you were
wearing my shoes okay which didn't even
fit the character yeah they really
that's not what Frank Castle would wear
and I was like why the [ __ ] is he
wearing my shoes but I remember seeing
you at I think it was it was at one of
these Hollywood I never go to these
things but it was at Lizzie kaplan's oh
yeah birthday party yeah
the best in the world so funny yeah and
I saw you there and I was literally like
can I I've been on your show can I go
say hello to you and I didn't I was too
shy to do it that's ridiculous so there
it goes for blay or whatever his name is
nah man he's right over there in the
corner nah man me and him are this I'm
as insecure as they get man I was like
[ __ ] I wish I could go and I literally
was one of those like should I should I
should and I totally okay so here's how
we we here's how one of the ways we're
different just before we started rolling
on this we were chatting and the
conversation started to get really good
and I thought wait a minute why aren't
we rolling it on this podcast that's how
fun it is to talk to John and I was like
we gotta we gotta get going on this
we've got to start rolling and the
reason I want to start rolling is that
you were telling a story that I can't
tell yes you were telling a story about
being at a it's the day before a wedding
and you got hit yep you got into a fight
and someone hit you with a bar stool
from behind guess what I don't have a
story like that it's not but look by the
way just to just to be clear I was I was
trying to break up a fight and and and
and and I got hit over that we were
talking about doctors and getting hurt
on things like motorcycles when you make
bad decisions yeah and I will never
forget I did we had gotten into a fight
there's a lot of ex-pro Fighters or Pro
fighters in Sean's family and I was
trying to break up the fight not fight
and a guy hit me from behind with one of
those outdoor uh bar stools and and I
got knocked out for a second and and I I
had to get all these staples across my
head and they shaved that part of my
head and I had all this dried blood
because I couldn't uh shower you know
and then I had to do my best man speech
looking like freaking Frankenstein but I
will never forget the look of disgust in
the doctors
you know I was I went there to be
treated and it was just like you [ __ ]
idiot like like I don't I I have to it
he was mad at you of course he was
because I'm out there probably he thinks
I'm talking smack at a bar and got you
probably thought I totally had it coming
and you know I tried to sort of you know
sell my side of the story to him he
wasn't interested at all John you don't
understand you have a story about
getting breaking up a bar fight by the
way if a bar fight breaks out yeah I
don't break it up okay I quickly I
quickly I run and I start swiping for an
Uber okay all my stories all my stories
that involve going to the hospital
revolve around like the medication they
prescribe I put a little too much cream
on my hand
slightly raised reddish area and yours
is uh man I'm trying to break up a bar
fight I get hit with a stool yeah that's
how we're different I gotta be more like
you I think you would have done this
teach me to be like you oh no man I
don't know you teach me man I it would
I'm not I'm not the least bit proud of
that but I I I will say that doctor I
could feel the palpable disgust and and
that is why I do ride my motorcycle and
my wife did sort of make a deal with me
years ago she said it's either boxing or
the motorcycle and that day I I rolled
my motorcycle down the street and I gave
it to there was a a guy uh old Phil who
lived down the street an old army vet I
gave him my motorcycle but now because I
think because of that bar stool I get
such terrible headaches when I box I've
quit sparring and I've quit mixing it up
in the ring so I'm back to the
motorcycle now but I am so afraid that
if I do get hurt the doctor is going to
look at me with that same level of
disgust because this is a decision that
I made myself yeah right stop going to
that doctor yeah maybe this doctor's
like this with everybody you think
that's right yeah maybe on like a a 75
year old woman comes in and says I think
I have chest pains you disgust me weekly
suck it up with your week third
Adventure
how dare